why are some kids sad what makes the
wind blow how do birds fly our world is
full of curious phenomena to find
answers or solve problems we can use a
process which was first acknowledged by
the scientist and philosopher eben
al-haytham in the 11th century also
known as our Hassan he's considered to
be the father of optics and the
scientific method there are six steps to
it one observe and ask questions to
research three formulate a hypothesis or
test your hypothesis five conclude six
share results the goal of the scientific
method is to find out the truth
let's try step one observe and question
observation helps us formulate
challenging questions that you will be
able to test a good question converts
the natural sense of wonder into a
focused line of Investigation when is
the best time to drive to school which
food is my dog's favorite for example if
you observe that woman's smile more
often than men you might ask why do
women smile more often step 2 research
find out if other people have asked the
same or similar questions if you
research online use search terms like
study research or meta-analysis which is
a summary of research for a specific
topic read as much as you can about your
particular subject to see what you can
find out about for example research
happiness based on gender or study the
science of smiling in different cultural
contexts
step3 formulate a hypothesis a
hypothesis is a theory that you can test
to see if your prediction is right or
wrong from your observation you have
noticed that women smile more often and
that people who are smiling seem to be
happy from your research you know that
there are different types of smiles shy
genuine and false in one paper you read
that baby girl's smile more often than
baby boys here is a hypothesis women
smile more than men because they are
happier than men step 4 test your
hypothesis when you test your hypothesis
you want to make sure to do this in a
fair way under the conditions are
constant for this hypothesis we can
design a test where an interviewer talks
with a set of men and women for five
minutes each counts how many times they
smile and then asks each one to rate
their level of happiness to get a good
sample of the population we invite 300
women and 300 men seems like a good test
right but wait what if the interviewer
is a woman and men tend to smile more at
women or vice versa or what if the topic
discussed is one that interests women
more than men and what if people aren't
reliable reporters of the right xual
level of happiness so clearly we would
need to be much more careful step 5
analyze and conclude let's assume that
you designed a very careful experiment
controlling for as many variables as
possible
now you can analyze the data to see if
your hypothesis is correct or incorrect
depending on your findings you may want
to change your hypothesis or change the
design of your testing perhaps you have
discovered an even more interesting
question this stage of the scientific
method can be repeated as many times as
necessary until you find just the right
hypothesis and test method to find
accurate results
step 6 share the results when you are
satisfied that you have proven or
disproven something important report
your results in science it is important
to detail your methods so that your
peers can review your work which is a
critical step to getting published if
your results are solid your experiment
can be repeated by other scientists such
reproducibility is a sign of good
scientific work but failed results can
also be interesting an incorrect
prediction could prove to be important
and should always be reported to make
sure you get it completely right here
are three more things you can check
before you publish a any scientific
theory is falsifiable real scientists
know that there is no such thing as a
scientific proof in other words you can
never prove your theory to be a hundred
percent right all you can do is find a
lot of supporting evidence that it could
be correct here is one example say that
someone says hamsters can fly we cannot
prove that this is false yes we have
never seen a hamster fly but we can't
test all possible conditions or look in
all possible places on the planet to
know that all hamsters never fly maybe a
space hamster does so while we can often
prove that a phenomenon exists it's much
harder to prove the non-existence of
something if your theory can't possibly
be proven wrong then it's not
falsifiable and hence not scientific B
correlation is not causation when you
analyze your results it is important to
separate between two possible reasons
correlation or causation let's say you
hear that towns that have more churches
also have more bars could it be that
religion makes people want to drink or
that drinking helps people to find God
if you add more facts such as larger
towns have both more bars and more
churches you can see that a large
halation is a more likely cause of
higher numbers of bars and churches
there is probably a correlation but no
causation if we compare men with women
and would conclude that women smile more
and are more happy then this still
doesn't mean that it's happiness that
makes them smile maybe they just eat
more chocolate and cookies which makes
them both happy and smile a lot
see avoid selective windowing when you
publish you've got to show all relevant
facts Colgate once run an advertising
campaign claiming that 80% of dentists
recommend Colgate what they didn't tell
us is that when they asked dentists to
select their preferred toothpaste
Colgate was just one of many other
brands they also recommended Colgate was
later sued and forced to take down their
misleading ads the purpose of science is
always to find out the truth and nothing
but the truth to use science to mislead
us is wrong and terrible business
practice let's do a last example
together I have two coins one is bigger
why the small coin says one cent the
bigger one says five AHA small coins are
worth less money bigger coins are worth
more money I pull some more coins from
my pocket two more pennies one more
nickel and a quarter dollar which is 25
cents great
my hypothesis seems true but wait is the
quarter worth more because it is bigger
so is that a correlation or a causation
hmm my sample size is pretty small I
don't think I am ready to report my
results can you help out please apply
the scientific method to study your
local currency maybe you have a
hypothesis that we can test until we get
solid repeatable results to report
please publish your findings in the
comments below
[Music]
you